ces villages une droite des terroirs une
droite des traditions une droite de la
transmission une droite qui est fière de
son histoire une droite qui ne l'a
déconstruit pas une droite qui la fait
vivre et vous savez que mon projet
c'était restaurer la fierté française
alors la dernière raison pour laquelle
je suis ici c'est parce qu'on est chez
eric ciotti
on est chez eric ciotti
[Applaudissements]
qui a fait qui a fait une formidable
campagne il a fait une formidable
campagne et vous le savez il ya une
bonne nouvelle aujourd'hui que je suis
venu partager avec vous habitant de la
vésubie c'est que la droite est de
retour
la droite est de retour et il ya une
formidable équipe de france qui s'est
levé dans cette primaire des
républicains
une droite qu'on attendait plus et dans
cette droite il y a une personnalité
singulière une personnalité singulière
qui s'appelle eric ciotti et qui est
l'héritier de charles pasqua à charles
pasqua grand ministre de l'intérieur
vous le savez et qui défendent est un
certain nombre de valeurs un certain
nombre de valeurs d'autorité
liberté et un certain nombre de valeurs
d'identité française et ce sont les
valeurs que défend aujourd'hui à mes
côtés eric ciotti et j'en suis très
heureuse et très fière
moi qui ai commencé aux côtés de jacques
chirac vous le savez avant de devenir
ministre de nicolas sarkozy moi qui leur
doit tout je sais à quel point la
victoire d'un chirac la victoire d'un
sarkozy doit à cette droite force forte
qui a toujours qui s'est toujours tenue
aux côtés des grands patrons des grands
candidat gaulliste alors ce que je suis
venu vous dire ici pour rassurer tous
ceux qui pourraient s'inquiéter c'est
que eric aura une place très singulière
dans ma campagne parce qu'il a une voix
très singulière à faire entendre pour le
pays
[Applaudissements]
et c'est vrai que les les adhérents des
républicains ont choisi avec nous sans
doute les candidats qui avaient les
valeurs les plus affirmées les valeurs
les plus clairs les projets j'allais
dire de droite assumé parce que
aujourd'hui les françaises se rendent
compte que ce sont nos solutions qui
sont les bonnes pour le pays ils se
rendent compte que notre pays a besoin
d'un choc d'autorité ils se rendent
comptent qu'aujourd'hui toutes les
figures d'autorité sont bafoués les
maires les élus les forces de l'ordre
les enseignants les médecins même les
pharmaciens par les anti pacs donc nous
avons besoin aujourd'hui de rétablir
l'ordre l'ordre à nos frontières l'ordre
dans nos rues l'ordre à l'école et c'est
pas dans ce beau département des
alpes-maritimes où tu m'avais fait venir
à la frontière de menton cher et que tu
me démentira nous avons besoin de dire
stop de dire stop au laxisme de dire
stop à une immigration incontrôlée et de
dire stop tout simplement aux lois
bafouées parce qu'un pays dont les lois
sont bafouées n'est plus un grand pays
alors mes chers amis avec eric nous
avons aussi en partage la volonté
réformatrice
alors il va plus loin que moi
sur certains thèmes
et donc je vais regarder si mon projet
peut être pimenté par un certain nombre
de ces suggestions
voilà
et je pense notamment je pense notamment
à aa quelque chose qu'il a dit durant
cette campagne qui était qui était qui
était fort à mon sens c'est quand il a
dit qu' il fallait qu'on travaille sur
sur la transmission notamment la
transmission des patrimoines de façon à
ce que nos jeunes puissent avoir le pied
à l'étrier et c'est très important
aujourd'hui vous savez que la crise que
vida a gonflé les parrainent des
français nous avons besoin de relancer
l'économie nous avons besoin de baisser
les impôts et c'est sur ces sujets là
que nous allons travailler ensemble eric
on le connaît sur les sujets régaliens
sur lesquels nous sommes déjà très
proches mais on le connaît moins sur sa
vision de l'économie il a une vision
profondément réformatrice nous étions
les deux seuls à assumer de dire que la
bureaucratie lippert bureaucratisation
de la société française est un fléau qui
nuit complètement à la compétitivité de
la france à l'emploi et à sa ré
industrialisation nous avons eu ce
courage et ensemble nous aurons le
courage de réformer la france
et puis il ya une autre conviction qui
nous unit c'est celle que la valeur
travail le mérite doivent être mis au
coeur de la société parce que tous les
deux on nous attendait pas
tous les deux nous nous sommes un peu
fait tout seul
tous les deux nous sommes allés au
combat avec j'allais dire notre audace
note panache et nos idées nos
convictions et c'est ça qui l'a emporté
et bien je vous le dis aujourd'hui je
vous donne rendez vous ici à saint
martin vésubie
parce que c'est le point de départ d'une
marche c'est le point de départ du tout
commence c'est le point de départ de
notre campagne victorieuse parce que je
le sais c'est l'audace c'est le panache
c'est les convictions c'est les
propositions qui font gagner on n'a pas
besoin d'être extrémiste pour être
offensif qu'on n'a pas besoin d'être
provoquant pour être convaincant
aujourd'hui le choix le choix de la
droite républicaine c'est le choix de la
crédibilité
c'est le choix des territoires c'est le
choix des présidents de départements des
présidents de régions des gens qui sont
au coeur des problèmes des français au
coeur de la vie quotidienne les deux
pieds ancrés dans le territoire et c'est
ça qui fait une connaissance intime de
la france c'est ça qui fait un lien
intime avec les français ce lien intime
qui manque tant à notre président de la
république qui est hors sol qui a une
présidence bavarde mais pas une
présidence active qui est en permanence
dans le plaire nous nous sommes dans le
faire alors c'est ça la recette gagnante
pour ces élections c'est d'aller à la
rencontre des français
parlé avec eux des problèmes de la
france montrer notre vision montrer nos
propositions leur redonner espoir alors
ici à saint martin vésubie commence une
campagne d'espoir avec un pilier eric
ciotti merci
[Applaudissements]
dans un certain nombre de propositions
et notamment moi j'ai été très sensible
dans le programme d'eric ciotti a tout
un volet que certains d'entre vous n'ont
peut-être pas bien vu qui est le volet
baisses d'impôts je pense qu'il faut
qu'on ait un peu plus loin dans les
baisses d'impôts pour les français pour
leur permettre de relancer l'économie et
de gagner plus ou de pouvoir transmettre
leur patrimoine notamment il a des
propositions très forte sur l'impôt sur
les successions donc c'est une piste de
d'amélioration du programme que nous
pourrons faire mais quoi qu'il arrive
c'est pas ça le message aujourd'hui ici
à saint martin vésubie le message ici
c'est que la droite est unie aujourd'hui
eric ciotti après sa magnifique campagne
aura une place singulière auprès de moi
dans la campagne la place que tenait un
charles
de jacques chirac auprès de nicolas
sarkozy
c'est cette droite que eric ciotti
incarne une droite forte une droite
d'autorité qu'il incarne il incarnera à
mes côtés ça veut dire que vous pourriez
supprimer l'impôt sur
ça veut dire ça veut dire que nous
allons travailler sur sur la question
des successions nous allons y travailler
pour l'instant je laisse cette clique
ouverte et je pense que c'était une des
mesures importantes qui projet d'eric
ciotti d'ailleurs je l'avais dit lors
d'années n'avait pas le droit de faire
cela le régalien de sécurité
l'immigration qu'on apporte ses élèves
c'est sur les 2 sur les deux plateaux
repas d'hier dans la campagne
ce sera un des piliers un des piliers de
ma campagne parce que vous allez mener
une campagne en tandem comme vous allez
le faire ce sera un pilier de ma
campagne vous savez nous sommes le parti
gaulliste et dans le parti gaulliste il
y a un chef en l'occurrence une chef et
il y à aussi à côté de ce chef il y à
des personnalités qui j'allais dire par
leur charisme par leurs convictions
porte des valeurs très fortes qui sont
évidemment indispensables pour la vie
est-ce que vous avez reçue
est ce que vous avez reçu de réponse
positive aux aux questions vous avez
posées notamment hier au port écoutez je
crois qu'aujourd'hui nous avons offert
avec d'abord de l'émotion dans le
village où réside toute mes racines dans
ce village juste parmi les nations dans
ce village qui a été marc tirl année
dernière une image d'unité de
rassemblement
je suis convaincu que valérie pécresse
va gagner cette élection présidentielle
je me battrai de toutes mes forces pour
qu'elle gagne cette élection
présidentielle parce que le pays en a
besoin notre pays est abîmée est
fracturée il est engagé sur le chemin du
déclin du déclassement beaucoup de
français souffrent jamais le pays n'a
été aussi en prise à la violence
jamais les familles n'ont autant
regarder l'avenir comme une menace et
non plus comme une espérance donc nous
avons besoin de redresser ce pays et
c'est dans la droite républicaine que
doit aujourd'hui
puiser la ressource pour bâtir le socle
d'une renaissance française moi je veux
que la france retrouve sa place je veux
qu'elle reste fidèle à elle même et je
suis convaincu que pour gagner cette
élection présidentielle valérie pécresse
aura besoin d'eux ces valeurs d'autorité
d'identité de liberté que nous avons
défendu ensemble et qu'elle aura besoin
de les porter au plus haut avec force
avec beaucoup d'audace et je veux être à
ses côtés avec elle celui qui portera
également ce message que m'ont confiées
et c'est une responsabilité c'est un
devoir et je resterai fidèle à ce
message les 44 mille militants qui m'ont
placé d'abord en tête au premier tour et
qui m'ont conduit à ce second tour ce
n'est peut-être pas un hasard s'il ya eu
cette configuration en second tour c'est
parce que avec valérie nous avions sans
doute les projets les plus similaires
les projets les plus audacieux en termes
de réformes de redressement des valeurs
qui s'associe à la droite pour moi être
de droite c'est aimer passionnément la
france sait mais son histoire son
héritage c'est croire en l'ordre
républicain c'est croire à la liberté
c'est vouloir récompenser le travail
c'est combattre le péril islamiste c'est
tout cela qui est incarne aujourd'hui
cette droite républicaine et les uns
dans cette campagne avec valérie
derrière elle c'est elle qui est élu
c'est elle qui a vocation à devenir le
chef de l'état je me battrai avec mes
convictions dans la fidélité à ses
valeurs je suis un homme de fidélité
je crois que c'est peut-être cela aussi
qu'on reconnu les militants fidélité à
la droite je suis un homme de droite je
l'assumé je crois que le pays a besoin
d'un cap clair à droite et ensemble nous
allons tenir ce cap solidement dans le
respect de nos engagements pour gagner
cette élection président des journées
d'aujourd'hui nous a rassurés sagesse
sur les transmissions d'être satisfait
les autres adversaires
la journée d'aujourd'hui vous a rassuré
c'est une belle série mais c'est une
belle journée il y en aura bien aura
beaucoup d'autres nous allons travailler
ensemble
voilà il ya eu un projet pour le congrès
chacun avait ses propositions nous
allons travailler ensemble pour passer à
d'autres étapes devant les français
valérie pécresse a cette responsabilité
et c'est son immense responsabilité son
grand devoir c'est de proposer aux
français un projet qui rassemble pour ma
part je veux amener dans ce projet des
éléments qui favorisent sa victoire
question